[Música]
en directo américa seguimos con nuestro
análisis diario de la guerra en ucrania
y todas sus aristas hoy nos enfocamos en
tres puntos importantes los civiles que
intentan vivir la nueva ronda de
diálogos y también el inicio en la allá
del juicio contra rusia por cometer
presuntamente crímenes de guerra se
cumplen 12 días de que rusia empezó la
invasión y moscú decidió abrir varios
corredores humanitarios para que los
civiles puedan salir de varias ciudades
de ese país asediada por esta guerra
algo que el gobierno ucraniano rechazó
ya que estos corredores van únicamente
hacia rusia y belarús anulando toda
posibilidad de que las personas lleguen
a europa todo esto en medio de una nueva
ronda de diálogos entre las partes que
no descartan la posibilidad de
solucionar el conflicto por una vía
diplomática además del inicio de la
audiencia en la corte internacional de
justicia me la cochrane acusa a rusia de
haber usado el falso término de
genocidio para así justificar la
invasión
audiencia a la que rusia no envió
representantes tampoco dejamos a un lado
las implicaciones cuando occidente y
café tienen sobre la mesa un posible
embargo al petróleo ruso y para ello
entonces saludamos a fernando 8 él es
analista de inteligencia y riesgos a la
seguridad nacional experto en terrorismo
y crímenes de odio gracias a fernando
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 hablemos entonces
principalmente de los civiles estos o
corredores humanitarios que además como
lo vimos fracasaron el fin de semana la
posibilidad de éxito dado a los
antecedentes como ya lo dijimos que
fracasaron en el sur del país
buenas tardes de aquí desde españa han
fracasado precisamente por una mala
planificación logística con un falta de
acuerdo entre en este caso las
relaciones internacionales tienes esos
corredores no pueden estar amparados
bajo la normativa de ucrania ni de rusia
tienen estar amparados por la normativa
de las leyes internacionales para que si
por ejemplo elementos como la cruz roja
o algún elemento internacional no a una
agencia nacional reconocida pudiera dar
la cobertura jurídica y así evitar este
problema el hecho de que estos
corredores se han destruido o no estén
funcionando también radica en los
intereses por parte de rusia de intentar
que acrecentar el conflicto y poner
contra las cuerdas al gobierno de
ucrania para que pueda renegociar o
negociar sus estatutos fernando y
estamos hablando de esa parte jurídica
para que realmente tengan efecto pero
también se tiene que contar digamos con
el apoyo de estas milicias en el terreno
para evitar entonces que sean combatidos
como como como poder evitar todo esto
más allá de la parte jurídica como
realmente estas tropas fue en
la vida de los civiles y que no se
convierta después en un problema mayor
también vamos a analizar lo que estamos
viendo lo que lo que pase nada ya pero
hablemos primero esto
precisamente esa es la forma al
encontrar un amparo jurídico por parte
de la cruz roja' por ejemplo por poner
un ejemplo
precisamente las milicias los ejércitos
son los que les dan el permiso para
hacer esos correos humanitarios y ellos
se responsabilizan de la protección o la
no agresión a los corredores que por
tanto han autorizado a esa entidad por
ejemplo a cruz roja esa es la forma de
proteger un corredor si no son
corredores unilaterales que siempre
serán atacados por la otra parte la
situación de los civiles se de fernando
que cada vez es más complicada y
realmente se va a empeorar en los
próximos días
sin duda va a ir cada vez peor por cada
vez faltarán más suministros la guerra
absorberá a todo el proceso logístico
que tenga en cada uno de cada país en
este caso ucrania y los civiles
evidentemente conseguirán lo poco que
que desea el suministro logístico tendrá
un problema de suministro energético y
hay ciudades que no tienen luz que no
tienen agua corriente y útil y
calefacción y por tanto que tampoco van
a tener apoyo logístico para apoyo de
infraestructuras para alimentación por
ejemplo transporte
acrecentarse cada vez más hasta que se
llegue a un acuerdo o se llegue
entiéndame la expresión así que se
llegue a limpiar de civiles una zona
para que no existe ese problema pero si
no van a sufrir muchísimo más claro y
además si tenemos en cuenta que estos
corredores humanitarios solamente por
ahora los rusos dicen que tienen que ir
en dirección hacia rusia y belarús y no
hacia europa también condicionando hacia
dónde pueden ir estas personas que
también tienen su libre albedrío de
decir muy para un lado y móvil para el
otro pero también usted está hablando un
punto muy importante y es de estos
diálogos un acuerdo diplomático hoy se
vuelven a reunir las delegaciones de
ucrania y rusia ya hemos visto dos
rondas anteriores
totalmente fallidas porque siguen
apelando a esta vía diplomática sin
ningún avance usted cree que realmente
puedan solucionar este conflicto por la
vía diplomática frenando
si realmente es que tenían que haberse
resuelto este conflicto por la vía
diplomática ya en el 2014 y 2018 cuando
estas dos progresivas acciones antes de
la toma de crimea y después con los
acuerdos ante sorpresa por demmings y
luego con la toma de crimea se establece
tiene establecer que tenían que haber
unos procedimientos para lograr una
independencia una votación en la
república independentista en el donbass
eso no se cumplió y amparo de eso putin
se ha justificado auto justificado en
esa invasión en lo que quiere siempre ha
dicho otra cosa es que lo cumpla o diga
la verdad un corredor de seguridad
nacional que vaya desde bielorrusia
hasta la península de crimea para
asegurarse de que ningún elemento de la
otan pueda atacar sus fronteras y eso es
lo que quiere cuando ucrania reconozca
eso utilice jara el ataque si no lo
reconoce no cejará en el ataque y
ucrania lo que quiere es no perder
territorio evidentemente ucraniano para
excederse lo a rusia en una república
independiente y lo que está haciendo es
solicitar ayuda de la europea y de la
otan en última instancia para poder
conseguir poner a putin en unas
circunstancias que le permitan negociar
de forma igualitaria cosa que es
extremadamente difícil ahora fernando
también hablemos de lo que ocurre en
este momento en la haya el inicio de la
audiencia en la corte internacional de
justicia
están diciendo a los ucranianos y los
ucranianos que rusia usó el testimonio
el término de genocidio y por eso ellos
demandan a rusia que está pasando allí
realmente esta demanda si ese procedente
como además le van a tomar los rusos
los rusos lo va a tomar muy malo
casimira va a tener en cuenta en la
demanda que tiene ucrania de genocidio y
está fundamentada sólo jurídicamente
parcialmente puesto que evidentemente
para rusia por ejemplo ucrania se
considera parte de ucrania se considera
parte de sus intereses culturales
étnicos y sociales por tanto a efectos
globales en la discusión en la haya va a
estar sobre si están o no están haciendo
acciones de genocidio en tanto que lo
que están pretendiendo seguramente es un
control territorial evidentemente son
los juristas que tienen que decir si
esto raya lo que es el genocidio o no
genocidio es decir si está atacando
sistemáticamente
si no se permite rendirse a las tropas y
por tanto no se atiene a los consejos de
ginebras a los acuerdo de ginebra y
entonces si se podría calificar de
genocidio pero eso hay que comprobarlo o
no hay periodistas en el terreno con una
cobertura jurídica en el terreno no se
puede demostrar e incluso perdonando
recordamos que los rusos ni siquiera
fueron a este inicio del juicio oral
también hablamos de otra parte
importante y evidentemente son las
sanciones económicas y todo lo que tiene
que ver el impacto de esta guerra en la
economía el posible embargo también que
hay sobre la mesa que maneja occidente y
ucrania a la petróleo ruso cómo sería
entonces esto en la afectación digamos a
la economía global a la economía mundial
sobre todo la energética ya vemos en
europa los precios disparados de la
energía
bueno primero hay que aclarar dos puntos
importantes a quién beneficia y a quién
perjudica a quién beneficia esta
situación aunque suene muy cruel es a
eeuu que está vendiendo al quíntuple de
su precio todo el gas licuado que tiene
y todas sus reservas de petróleo
materias primas y energía en este caso
tecnología punta de energía y por otro
lado rusia lo que tiene que hacer lo que
está haciendo ya de hecho ya ha firmado
es que todo su producto energético todo
su petróleo todo su gas todas sus
materias primas van a ir directamente
hacia asia y china se los va a comprar